[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright this is cs50 and this is lecture
4 also we're here in beautiful Lowe
lecture halls and Sanders is in use
today and we're joined by some friends
that will soon be clear and present in
just a moment but before then recall
that last time we took a look at cs50
IDE this was a new web-based programming
environment similar in spirit to cs50
sandbox in cs50 lab but added a few
features for instance what features did
it add to you to your capabilities yeah
what's that the debugger so debug 50
which opens that side panel that allows
you to step through your code step by
step and see variables yeah sorry say
again check 50 as well which is a cs50
specific tool that allows you to check
the correctness of your code much like
the Teaching Fellows would when
providing feedback on it running a
series of tests that pretty much are the
same tests that a lot of the homeworks
will encourage you yourself to run
manually but it just automates the
process and anything else
so that is true - there's a little
hidden easter egg that we don't use this
semester but yes indeed if you look for
a small puzzle piece you can actually
convert your C code back to scratch like
puzzle pieces and back and forth and
back to forth thanks to cream and some
of the team so that is there but by now
is probably better to get comfortable
with text as well so there's a couple of
other tools that we've used over time of
course besides check50 and debug 50
we've of course to use printf and when
is printf useful like when might you
want to use it beyond needing to just
print something because the problems
that tells you - yeah yeah sort of find
where your bug is if you just kind of
want to print out a variables value or
some kind of texture so you know what's
going on and you don't necessarily want
to deploy debug 50 you can do that one
else good yeah indeed well in real life
so you might want to use printf when you
have maybe a nested loop and you want to
put a printf in the inside loop so as to
see when it kicks in of course you could
use debug 50 and but you might end up
running debug 50 or clicking next next
next next next next there's so many
times that that gets a little tedious
but do keep in mind you could just put a
breakpoint deeper into your code as well
and perhaps remove an earlier breakpoint
as well and honestly all the time
whether it's in C or other languages do
I find myself occasionally using printf
just to type out printf in here just so
that I can literally see if my code got
to a certain point in here to see if
something's printed but the debugger
you're gonna find now and henceforth
so much more powerful so much more
versatile so if you haven't already
gotten to the habit of using debug 50 by
all means start and use those
breakpoints to actually walk through
your code where you can't see what's
going on so style 50 of course checks
the style of your code much like the
Teaching Fellows might and it shows you
in red or green what spaces you might
want to delete what spaces you might
want to add just to pretty things up so
it's more readable for you and others
and then what about help 50 when should
you instinctively reach for help 50 yeah
exactly yeah when you don't understand
an error message so you're compiling
something you're running a command it
doesn't really quite work and you're
seeing a cryptic error message
eventually you'll get the muscle memory
and the sort of exposure to just know oh
I remember what that means but until
then run help 50 at the beginning of
that same command and it's gonna try to
detect what your error is and provide TF
like feedback on how to actually work
around that you'll see two on the
courses website is a wonderful handouts
made by Emily Hong one of our own
teaching fellows that introduces all of
these tools and a few more and gets you
into the habit of thinking about things
it's kind of a flowchart if I have this
problem then do this else if I have this
problem do this other thing so do check
that out as well but today let's
introduce really the last certainly
foresee of our command-line tools that's
gonna help you chase down problems in
your code last week
recall that we had talked about memory a
lot we talked about malloc allocating
memory and we talked about freeing
memory and the like but it turns out you
can do a lot of damage when you start
playing with memory in fact probably by
now almost everyone segmentation fault
yeah so that's just one of them errors
that you might run into and frankly you
might have errors in your code now and
henceforth that have bugs but you don't
even realize it because you're just
getting lucky and the program is just
not crashing or it's not freezing but
this can still happen and so valgrind is
a command line program that is probably
looks the scariest of the tools we've
used but you can also use it with help
50 that just tries to find what are
called memory leaks in your program
recall that last week we introduced
malloc and Malak lets you allocate
memory but if you don't free that memory
by literally calling the free function
you're gonna constantly ask your
operating system Mac OS Linux Windows
whatever can I have more memory can I
have more memory can I have more memory
and if you never literally hand it back
by calling free your computer may very
well slow down or freeze or crash and
frankly if you've ever had that happen
on your Mac or PC very likely that's
what some human accidentally did he or
she just allocated more and more memory
but never really got around to freeing
that memory so valgrind can help you
find those mistakes before you or your
users do so let's do a quick example let
me go into cs50 IDE and let me go ahead
and make one new program
here we'll call it memory dot C because
we'll see later today how I might chase
down those memory leaks but for now
let's start with something even simpler
which all of you have maybe done by now
which is to accidentally touch memory
that you shouldn't changing it reading
it and let's see what this might mean so
let me do the familiar at the top here
include standard i/o well let's not even
do that yet let's just do this first
let's do int main void just to start a
simple program and in here let me go
ahead and just call a function called F
I don't really care what its name is for
today I just want to call a function f
and then that's it now this function f
let me go ahead and define it as follows
void f void it's not gonna do much of
anything at all but let's suppose just
for the sake of discussion that FS
purpose in life is just allocate memory
for whatever useful purpose but for now
it's just for demonstrations sake so
what's the function with which you can
allocate memory malloc so suppose I want
to malloc space for I don't know
something simple like just one integer
like we're just doing this for
demonstration purposes or actually let's
do a more 10 integers 10 integers I
could of course do well give me 10 but
how many bytes do I want how many bytes
do I need for 10 integers yeah so I can
do literally size of int and most likely
the size of an int is gonna be or
probably on many systems today it's just
4 bytes or 32 bits but you don't want a
hard code that list someone else's
computer not use those same values so
the size of an int so 10 times the size
of an it malloc returns what type of
data what is it can hand me back yeah it
returns an address or a pointer
specifically the address 100 900
whatever of the chunk of memory it just
allocated for you so if I want to keep
that around I need to declare a pointer
let's just call it X for today that
stores that address could call it XYZ
whatever but it's not an int that it's
returning it's the address of an int and
remember that's what the star operator
now means the address of some data type
it's just a number all right so now if I
were to first let's clean this up turns
out that to use malloc I need to use
standard Lib dot H we saw that last
albeit briefly and then of course if I'm
gonna call F what do I have to do to fix
this code yeah I need to declare it up
here or I could just move F's
implementation up top so I think this
works even though this program at the
moment it's completely stupid it doesn't
do anything useful but it will allocate
memory and now do something with it as
follows if I want to change the first
value in this chunk of memory
well how might I do that well I've asked
the computer for 10 integers or strether
space for 10 integers what's interesting
about malloc is that when it returns a
chunk of memory for you it's contiguous
back to back and when you hear
contiguous or back to back what kind of
data structure does that recall to mind
in array so it turns out we can treat
this just random chunk of memory like
it's an array so if we want to go to the
first location in that array of memory I
can just do this and put in the number
say 50 or if I want to go to the next
location I can do this or if I want to
do the next location I can do this or if
I want to go to the last location I
might do this but is that good or bad
why bad
yeah so it's out of balance right this
is sort of week one style mistakes when
it came to loops recalled with four
loops or while loops you might go a
little too far and that's fine but now
we actually will see we have a tool that
can help us notice these things so
hopefully just visually it's apparent
that what I have going on here is just
on line 12 I have a variable X that's
storing the address of that chunk of
memory and then on line 13 I'm just
trying to access location 10 and set the
value 50 there but as you note there is
no location 10 there's location 0 1 2 3
all the way through 9 of course so how
might we detect this with the program
well let me go ahead and increase my
terminal window just a bit here save my
file and let me go ahead and compile
make memory ok all is well it compiled
without any error messages and now let
me go ahead and run memory enter all
right so that worked pretty well let's
actually be a little more explicit here
just for good measure let me go ahead
and print something out so printf % I
for an integer and now let's make it
this more explicit you inputted % I and
then comma X bracket 10 and what do I
have to include to use printf yeah so
standard i/o so let's just quickly add
that standard i/o dot H save all right
let me recompile this make memory enter
and now let me go ahead and do dot slash
whoops dot slash memory ha feels like
it's a correct program and yet for a
couple weeks now we've been claiming
that don't do that like don't go beyond
the boundaries of your array so how do
we reconcile this feels like buggy code
or at least we've told you it's buggy
code and yet it's working yeah
that's a good way of putting it like
okay well yeah and I think if I heard
you correctly you said see doesn't
scream if you go too far yeah okay so
that's a good way of putting it like you
can get lucky in C and you can do
something that is objectively
pedagogically like technically you're
wrong but the computer is not going to
crash it's not going to freeze because
you just get lucky because often for
performance reasons when you allocate
safe space for 10 integers you're
actually gonna get a chunk of memory
back
that's a little bigger than you need
it's just not safe to resume that it's
bigger than you need but you might just
get lucky and you might end up having
more memory that you can technically get
away with touching or accessing or
changing and the computer's not gonna
notice but that's not safe because on
someone else's Mac or PC their computer
might just be operating a little bit
differently than yours and bam that bug
is gonna bite them and not you and those
are the hardest most annoying bugs to
chase down as some of you might have
experienced right it works on your
computer but not a friend's or vice
versa these are the kinds of
explanations for that so valgrind can
help us track down even these most
subtle errors program seems to be
working check 50 or tools like it might
even assume that it's working because it
is printing the right thing but let's
take a look at what this program
valgrind thinks let me increase the size
of the terminal window here and go ahead
and type in valgrind dot slash memory so
same program name dot slash memory but
I'm pre fixing it with the name
valgrind all right unfortunately
valgrind is really quite ugly and it
prints out a whole bunch of stuff here
so let's take a look at the very top
you'll see all these numbers on the left
and that's just an unfortunate aesthetic
but we do see some useful information
invalid read of size 4 and then it has
these cryptic looking letters and
numbers what what are those they're just
addresses in hexadecimal it doesn't
really matter what they are but valgrind
can tell us where the memory is that's
acting up suspiciously you can then see
next to that that valgrind is pointing
to function f on memory dot sees 15th
line so that's perhaps helpful and then
main on line 8 because that's the
function that was called so valgrind is
actually kind of nice in that it's
showing us all the functions that you
called from bottom up much like
the stack from last week and so
something's going wrong on line 15 and
if we go back to that let's see line 15
was sure enough I'm actually trying to
access that memory location and frankly
I did an on line 14 as well so hopefully
fixing one or both of those will address
this issue so and notice here this
frankly just gets overwhelming pretty
quickly and then Oh 40 bytes in one
blocks are definitely lost in lost
record I mean this is the problem with
valor and honestly it was written some
years ago not particularly user-friendly
but that's fine we have a tool to
address this let me go ahead and rerun
valgrind with help 50 enter and see if
we can't just assist with this all right
so still the same amount of black and
white input but down here now help 50 is
noticing oh I can help you with an
invalid write of size 4 so it's still at
the same location but this time or
rather same file memory dot C but line
14 and we proposed looks like you're
trying to modify four bytes of memory
that isn't yours question mark did you
try to store something beyond the bounds
of an array take a closer look at line
14 of memory dot C so hopefully even
though valgrind output is crazy esoteric
like at least that yellow output will
point you toward a line 14 I'm indeed
touching four bytes in integer that I
shouldn't be and so let's go ahead and
fix this if I go into my program and I
don't do this let's change it to
location nine and location nine here and
save then let me go ahead and rerun
valgrind without help 50 all right
progress except oh nope not progress I
skipped a step yeah I didn't read
compile it it's a little puzzled why I
saw the same thing so now let's rerun
valgrind and here it seems to be better
so I don't see that same error message
up at the very top like we did before
but notice here 40 bytes in one blocks
okay that was bad grammar in the program
but are definitely lost in lost record
one of one so I still don't quite
understand that no big deal let's go
ahead and run help 50 and see what the
second of two errors apparently is here
so here it's highlighting those lines 40
bytes and one blocks are definitely lost
and looks like your program leaked 40
i'ts of memory did you forget to free
memory that you allocated with malloc
take a closer look at line 13 of memory
dot C so in this case line 13 indeed has
a call to malloc so what's the fix for
this problem / help 50 or your own
intuition what do I have to add to this
program yeah free you and where does
that go
writes here so we can free the memory
why would this be bad exactly we're
freeing the memory which is like saying
the operating system I don't need this
anymore and yet two lines later we're
using it again and again so bad we
didn't do that mistake last week but you
should only be freeing memory when
literally you're ready to free it up and
give it back which would probably be at
the end of the program so let me go
ahead and resave this open up my
terminal window recompile it this time
and now let me run valgrind one last
time without help 50 and still a little
verbose but zero errors from zero
contexts that sounds pretty good and
moreover it also explicitly says all
heap blocks were freed and recall that
the heap is that chunk of memory that we
drew visually up here is which is where
my life takes memory from so done so
this is kind of the mentality with which
to have that to have when approaching
the correctness of your code like it's
one thing to run sample inputs or run
the program like I did all looked well
it's one thing to run tools like check
50 which we humans wrote but we too are
fallible certainly and we might not
think of anything and thankfully smart
humans have made tools that at first
glance might be a little hard to use
like debug 50 as is valgrind nanaue but
they ultimately help you get your code a
hundred percent correct without you
having to like struggle visually over
just staring at the screen and we see
this a lot in office hours honestly a
lot of students to their credit sort of
reasoning through staring at the screen
just trying to understand what's going
wrong but they're not taking any
additional input other than the
characters on the screen you have so
many tools that can feed you more and
more hints along the way so do acquire
those instincts any questions on this
yeah
a main function that took arguments
would you run valgrind with those
arguments as well yes indeed
so valgrind works just like debug 50
just like help 50 if you have
command-line arguments just run them as
usual but prefix your command with
valgrind or maybe even help 50 valgrind
to help one with the other good question
other thoughts yeah
good question so at the end of the day
think about what's inside the computer
which is just something like this so
physically it's obviously still there
it's just being treated by the operating
system Mac OS Windows Linux whatever is
like a pool of memory we keep drawing it
as a grid that looks a little something
like this so the operating systems job
is to just keep track of which of those
squares is in use thanks to malloc and
which has been freed and so you can
think of it as having little checkmarks
next to them saying this is in use this
is in use these others are not in use so
they just go back on the so called free
list into that pool of memory good
question if you take a higher level
course on operating systems in factor C
a 61 or 161 at Harvard you'll actually
build these kinds of things yourself and
implement tools like malloc yourself
yeah good question why did we have to
allocate memory in this case we did not
this was purely as mentioned for
demonstration purposes if we had some
program in which we wanted to allocate
some amount of memory then this is how
we might do it however a cleaner way to
do all of this would have been to say
hey computer give me 10 integers like
this and not have to worry about memory
management and that's where we began in
week 1 just using arrays on the stack so
to speak not using malloc at all so the
point is only that once you start using
malloc and free and memory more
generally you take on more
responsibilities than we did in week 1
good question any others all right
so turns up there's one more tool in all
seriousness this is a thing DBB 50 so
debug 50 is an allusion to a very
popular tool called gdb 50 good new
debugger it's an older tool that you
won't use at the command-line but it's
what makes debug 50 work turns out
there's a thing and there's an actual
Wikipedia article that you might have
clicked on in my email last night they
called rubber duck debugging and frankly
you don't have to go as all outs as
excessive as we did here but the purpose
of this technique of rubber duck
debugging is to keep literally like a
rubber duck on your shelf or on your
desk and when you have a bug and you
don't have the luxury of a Teaching
Fellow or a roommate who took cs50 or a
more technical friend who can help walk
you through
code literally start walking through
your code verbally talking to the duck
saying well online - I'm declaring Maine
and on line three I'm allocating space
for an array and then on line four I'm
calling all that's what I'm doing wrong
so if any of you have ever had that kind
of moment whether an office hours are
alone where you're either talking in
your head or you're talking through your
code to someone else and he or she
doesn't even have to respond you just
hear yourself saying the wrong thing or
having that aha moment you can
approximate that by just keeping one of
these little guys on your desk and have
that conversation and it's actually not
as crazy sounding as it actually is it's
that process of just talking through
your code logically step-by-step in a
way that you can't necessarily do in
your own mind at least I can't when you
hear yourself say something wrong or
that didn't quite follow logically BAM
you can actually have that aha moment so
on the way out today by all means take
any one of these ducks that took quite a
long time for occult until a out today
and we'll have more at office hours in
the weeks to come if you would like so
you might some of you might recall such
a duck from Currier house last year -
which was a cousin of his as well
alright so that is rubber duck debugging
now last week
recall that we began to take off
training wheels we'd use for a few weeks
the cs50 library and that's kind of in
the past now that was just a technique a
tool via which we could get user input a
little more pleasantly than if we
actually started dueling with memory
early on and we revealed last week that
a string quote unquote is just what
underneath the hood in see what's again
an array of characters and even more
specifically it's a synonym STR ing for
what actual data type char star as we've
called it so a char star is just the
computer scientist way of describing a
pointer to a character or rather the
address of a character which is
functionally equivalent to saying in an
array of memory or sequence of memory
but it's kind of the more precise more
technical way of describing it and so
now that we know that we have char stars
underneath the hood well where is all of
that coming from one deed it Maps
directly to that memory we keep pointing
out that something like this is inside
of your computer and we can think of the
memory as just being chunks of memory
all of whose bytes are number
zero on up to two gigabytes or two
billion whatever the value might be but
of course last week we pointed out that
you think about this memory not as being
Hardware per se but it's just being this
pool of memory that's divided into
different regions the very top of your
computer's memory so to speak is what we
call the text segment and what goes in
the text segment of your computer's
memory when you're running a program
text is like poor choice of words
frankly but what is it
I say again not the file headers in this
case this is in the context of running a
program not necessarily saving a file
yeah not string literals here but
they're nearby actually in memory
functions closer yeah the text segment
of your computer's memory is where when
you double-click a program to run it or
in Linux when you dot do dot slash
something to run it that's where the
zeros and ones of your actual program
the machine code that we talked about in
week zero is just loaded into Ram
so recall from last week that you know
heart anything physical in this world
hard drive solid-state drives is slow so
those devices are slow but Ram the stuff
we keep pulling up on the screen is
relatively fast if only because it has
no moving parts it's purely electronic
so when you double-click a program on
your Mac or PC or do dot slash something
in Linux that is loading from a slow
device your hard drive where the data is
stored long term into RAM or memory
where it can run much more quickly and
pleasurably in terms of performance and
so what does this actually mean for us
well it's got to go somewhere we just
decided humans years ago that it's going
to go at the top so to speak of this
chunk of memory below that though are
the more dynamic regions of memory the
stack and the heap and we said this a
moment ago in last week as well
what goes on the heap or who uses the
heap dynamic memory anytime you call
malloc you're asking the operating
system for memory from the so called
heap anytime you call free you're sort
of conceptually putting it back like
it's not actually going anywhere you're
just marking it as available for other
functions and variables to use the stack
meanwhile is used for what local
variables and any of your functions so
main typically takes a sliver
memory at the bottom if main calls
another function it gets a sliver of
memory above that if that function calls
one it gets a sliver of memory above
that so they each have their own
different regions of memory but of
course these arrows both pointing at
each other doesn't seem like such a good
design but the reality is bad things can
happen you can allocate so much memory
that BAM the stack overflows the heap or
the heap overflows the stack thus was
born websites like Stack Overflow
and the like but that's just a reality
if you have a finite amount of memory at
some point something's going to break or
the computer is going to have to say mmm
no more memory you're going to have to
quit some programs or close some files
or whatnot so that was only to say that
that's how the memory is laid out and we
started to explore this but we have a
few programs this one here it's a little
dark here this one here was a swap
function and how it's even darker it was
a swap function that actually did swap
two values a and B but it didn't
actually work in the way we intended
what was broken about this swap function
last week like I'm pretty sure it worked
and when our brave volunteer came up and
swapped the orange juice in the milk
that works so like the logic was correct
but the program itself did not work why
exactly it changed values in the copies
of the variable so recall that when main
was the function we called and it had
two values x and y that chunk of memory
was here that chunk of memory was here
in a head like the numbers 1 & 2 but
when it called the swap function that
got its own chunk of memory so main was
at the bottom swap was above that it had
its own chunks of memory called a and B
which initially got the values 1 & 2 1 &
2 were indeed successfully swapped but
that had no effect on X & Y so we fixed
that with the newer version of this
program of course it looked a lot more
cryptic at first glance but in English
could someone just describe what it is
that happened in this example that was
more correct like what does this program
do line by line yeah
exactly instead of passing the values of
the variables that are by copying them
it passes the addresses of those
variables so that's like saying I don't
technically care where it is in memory
but I do need to know that it is
somewhere in memory so when instead of
passing an X and the number one let's
suppose that X is at location 100 my
go-to example it's actually the number
100 that's going to go there and if Y is
at the location like 104 well it's 104
that's going to go there which are not
the values we want to swap but those are
sort of like little Maps or breadcrumbs
if you will that lead us to the right
location so that when we execute this
code what we're all Tamang in those
three lines is this in this and all
along the way recall we're using a
temporary variable there that can be
just thrown away after so that's what
pointers allowed us to do and that's
what allowed us to actually change
values on the so called stack even
though even by calling another function
or any questions then on where we left
off last time with the stack and with
swap all right so recall we introduced
binky as well who lost his head at one
point but why what went horribly
horribly awry with the scene from last
week's film from Stanford binky was
doing everything correctly right like
moving values 42 was successful and then
yeah exactly he tried to dereference a
pointer an address that wasn't actually
pointing to a valid address recall that
this was the line encode in question
that was unlucky and bad star y means go
to the address in Y and do something to
it set it equal to the number 13 but the
problem was that in the code we looked
at last week all we did at the start was
say hey computer give me a pointer to an
int and call it X do the same and give
it and call it Y allocates space and
points X at it but we never did the same
for y so whereas X contained last week
the address of an actual chunk of memory
thanks to malloc what did Y contain at
that point in the story the yellow line
there
what did why contain what value no maybe
maybe but it's not obvious because
there's no mention of null on the
program we might get lucky
null is just zero and sometimes we've
seen that zero are the default values in
a program so maybe but I say maybe and
I'm hedging why yeah and it doesn't
allocate well allocates not quite the
right word that suggests you are
allocating actual memory it's a garbage
value there's something there right my
Mac has been running for a few hours and
your Macs and PCs and phones are
probably running all day long or
certainly when the lid is up and so your
memory is getting used and unused and
used like lots of stuff is going on so
your computer is not filled with like
all zeros or all ones if you look at it
at some random point in the day it's
filled with like bunches and bunches of
zeros and ones from previous programs
that you quit long ago windows you have
in the background and the like so the
short of it is when you're running a
program for the first time that's been
running now for some time it's gonna get
messy that big rectangle of memory is
gonna have some ones over here some
zeros over here and vice versa so
they're garbage values because those
bytes have some values in them you just
don't necessarily know what they are so
the point is you should never ever
dereference a pointer that you have not
set yourself maybe it will crash maybe
it won't crash valgrind can help you
find these things but sometimes but it's
just not a safe operation all right and
lastly the last thing we introduced last
week which will be the stepping stone
for what problems will solve this week
was struct so struct is kind of cool in
that you can design your own custom data
structures C is pretty limited out of
the box so to speak
you only have chars and bulls and floats
and intz and doubles and Long's and
Stroke we don't even have strings per se
so it doesn't really come with many
features like a lot of languages do like
Python which we'll see in a few weeks so
with structs in c you have the ability
to solve some problems of your own for
instance with the struct we can actually
start to implement our own features or
our own data types for instance let me
go up here and let me go ahead and
create a file called say student
they're destruct so recall that dot H is
a header file thus far we you have used
header files that other people made like
cs50.h and standard IO dot H and
standard lid but H but you can make your
own header files or just files that
typically contain code that you want to
share across multiple programs and we'll
see more of this in time so let me go
ahead and just save this file and
suppose that I want to represent a
student in memory a students of course
is probably going to have what like a
for instance how about a string for
their name a string for their dorm but
string is kind of two weeks ago let's
call this char star and let's call name
char star and so you might want to
associate like multiple pieces of data
with a student right and you don't to
have multiple variables per se it'd be
nice to kind of encapsulate these
together and recall at the very end of
last week we saw this feature where you
can define your own type with type death
that is a structure itself and you can
give it a name so in short simply by
executing this these lines of code you
have just created your own custom data
type it's now called student and every
students in the world shall have per
this code a name and a dorm associated
with them now why is this useful well
the program we looked at at the very end
of last time looked a little something
like this
instructs 0 dot C we had the following i
first allocated some amount of space for
students i asked the user what's the
enrollment in the class or what not that
gives us an INT and then we allocated an
array of type student called students
plural this was an alternative recall to
doing something like this string names
enrollment and string dorms enrollment
which would work you could have two
separate arrays and you just have to
remember that name 0 and dorm 0 is the
same human but why do that if you can
keep things together so with structs we
were able to do this give me this many
student structures and call the whole
array students and the only new syntax
we introduced to satisfy this goal was
what operator
the dot yeah so in the past recall from
like week two we introduced arrays and
arrays allow you to do square bracket
notation so that is no different from a
couple of weeks back but if your array
is not storing just integers or chars or
floats or whatever it's actually storing
a structure like a student you can get
at that student's name by literally just
saying dot name and you can get at their
dorm by doing dot dorm and then
everything else is the same
this is what's called encapsulation and
it's kind of like a fundamental
principle of programming where if you
have some real world entity like a
student and you want to represent
students with code yeah you could have a
bunch of arrays that all have called de
names dorms emails phone numbers but
that just gets messy you can instead
encapsulate all of that related
information about a student into one
data structure so that now you have per
week zero and abstraction like a student
is an abstraction and if we break that
abstraction what is a student actually
not in the real world but in our code
world here student is an abstraction
it's a useful word all of us can kind of
agree mean something but technically
what does it apparently mean a student
is actually a name in a dorm which
really kind of is diminutive to everyone
in this room but we've distilled it in
code to just those two values so there
we have encapsulation you're kind of
encapsulating together multiple values
and you're abstracting away just have a
more useful term because no one's going
to want to talk in terms of lines of
code to describe anything so same topic
is in the past so now we have the
ability to come up with our own custom
data structures it seems that we can
store anything inside of them that we
want so let's now see how poorly we've
been designing some things for the past
few weeks so it turns out that much of
the code hopefully we've been writing in
recent weeks has been correct but we've
been not necessarily designing solutions
in the best way we're called it when we
have this chunk of memory we've
typically treated it as at most in array
so just a contiguous chunk of memory and
thanks to this very simple mental model
do we get strings do we get arrays of
students now but arrays aren't
necessarily the best data structure in
the world like what is a downside of an
array
if you've encountered ones thus far in C
what's a downside of an array
yeah tanner cannot you cannot that is
true so in C you cannot mix data types
inside of an array they must all be in
stay must all be charged they must all
be students it's a bit of a white lie
because technically you can have
something called a void star and you can
actually map but yes that is true though
strictly speaking cannot mix data types
though frankly even though other
languages let you do that it's not
necessarily the best design decision but
sure a limitation other thoughts yeah
the size cannot change let's focus on
that one because that's sort of more
even more constraining it would seem so
if you want an array for say two values
what do you do well you can do something
like int X bracket 2 semicolon and what
does that actually give you inside of
your computer's memory it gives you some
chunk that will draw as a rectangle with
this is location 0 this is location 1
suppose that oh a few minutes later you
change your mind oh darn I just took a I
want to type in a third value or I want
to add another student to the array
where do you put that well you don't if
you want to add a third value to an
array of size two what's your only
option in C you make a new array so
literally and if this array had the
number like 42 and this had the number
13 the only way to add a third number is
to allocate a third of the second array
copy the values into the same locations
42 13 and then we'll add another value
50 and then so that you're not using up
twice as much space almost permanently
now you can sort of free somehow or stop
using that chunk of memory so that's
fine it's correct what we just did but
what's the running time of that process
call a couple weeks ago we started
talking about efficiency in design
what's the running time of resizing in
array say again too long fair but let's
be more precise Big O of Big O of what
and what's N okay true but what does n
represent yeah so you don't actually
have to not know like it's just a
general answer in this case however long
the array is call it n it is that many
steps to resize it into that plus one
okay technically it's Big O of n plus
one but recalling our discussion to Big
O notation we just ignore the smaller
terms the plus ones that divided by twos
the plus n we focus only on the most
powerful term in the expression which is
just n here so yes if you have an array
of size two and you resize it into an
array of size three or really n plus one
that's gonna take me roughly n steps
technically n plus 1 steps but n steps
ergo Big O of n so it's a linear process
so possible but not necessarily the
fastest thing because we literally have
to move all those damn values around so
what would be better than this and if
you program before you might have the
right instincts already how do we solve
this problem oh yeah we allocate more
memory at the end of the array so it
turns out C does have a function called
realloc perfectly if not obviously named
that reallocates memory and if you pass
it the address of a chunk of memory
you've allocated and the operating
system notices oh yeah you got lucky
I've got more memory at the end of this
array it will then allocate that
additional RAM for you and let you use
it or worse case if there's nothing
available at the end of the array in
memory because it's being used by
something else in your program that's
fine realloc will take take on the
responsibility of creating another array
somewhere in memory copying all of that
data for you into it and returning the
address of that new chunk of memory
unfortunately that's still linear yeah
this is all being done in the heap Malik
and realloc and free all operates on the
heap yes
so that is a solution but it doesn't
really speak to the efficiency yeah yeah
what is a linked list okay
points to other element yeah so let me
speak to like what's the fundamental
issue here the fundamental problem is
that like much like painting yourself
into a corner so to speak as the cliche
goes with an array you were deciding in
advance how big the data structure is
and committing to it well what if you
just do the opposite don't do that if
you want initially room for just one
value say one integer only ask the
computer for that give me space for one
integer and I'll put my number 42 in
here and then if and only if you want a
second integer do you ask the computer
for a second integer and so the computer
as by a malloc or whatnot will give you
another one like the number 13 and if
you want a third just ask the same
question of the operating system each
time just getting back one chunk of
memory but there's a fundamental gotcha
here there's always a trade-off so yes
this is possible you can call malloc
three times each time asking for a chunk
of memory of size 1 instead of size 3
for instance but what's the price you
pay or what problem do we still need to
solve yeah yeah they're not being stored
next to each other so even though I can
think of this as being the first element
the second and the third you do not have
in this story random access to elements
in random access ergo random access
memory or Ram just means that arithmetic
leak like mathematically you can jump to
location zero location one location two
randomly or in constant time just
instantly because if they're all back to
back to back all you have to do is like
add one or add four or whatever to the
address and you're there but the problem
is if you're calling malloc again and
again and again there's no guarantee
that these things are even going to be
proximal to one another these second
chunks of memory might end up if this is
the big chunk of memory we've been
talking about where the heaps of bahir
and the
down here 42 might end up over here the
next chunk of memory 50 might end up
over here
the third chunk might end up over here
so there you can't just jump from
location 0 to 1 to 2 because you have to
somehow remember where location 0 and 1
and 2 are so how do we solve this even
if you haven't programmed before like
what would a solution be here okay
somehow storing the addresses of all
right so let's just suppose for the sake
of discussion that this chunk of memory
ended up at location 100 this one ended
up at like 150 this one ended up at like
475 whatever those values are it would
seem that somehow or other I need to
remember three values 100 150 and 475 so
where can I store that well it turns out
I could be a little clever but a little
greedy I could say to malloc you know
what every time I call you don't just
give me space for an integer give me
space for an integer plus the address of
another integer so if you've ever kind
of seen like popcorn strung together on
a string or any kind of chain-link fence
where one link is linking to another we
could create the equivalent of whoops
not that we could create the equivalent
of this kind of picture where each of
these squares or nodes will start
calling them kind of links graphically
to the other well we've seen these links
or these pointers literally arrows that
are pointing implemented in code an
arrow or a pointer is just an address so
you know what we should just ask Mal'akh
not for enough space for just the number
42
we should instead ask for a little more
memory in each of these squares making
them pictorially rectangles now so that
now yes we do have these arrows
conceptually pointing from one location
to another
but what values do I actually want to
put in these new additional boxes the
addresses of the next so if they're like
little breadcrumbs so in this box here
associated with the first value should
be the address of my second value
five associated with my second value
here per the arrow and let me draw the
arrow from the right place from the
arrow should be the address 150 because
that's the last and then from this extra
box what should I put there yeah yeah so
probably the equivalent slash zero which
in the world of pointers recall is n ul
L so just a special value that means
that's it this is the end of the line
that still leaves us with room to add a
fourth value and point to it but it for
now signifies very clearly to us there's
nothing actually there so what did we
just do we created a list of values 50
or sorry forty to fifty thirteen but we
linked them together first pictorially
with just arrows like any human might
with a UH piece of chalk but technically
in code we could do this by just storing
addresses in each of these places so
just to be clear then what might this
actually translate to in code well what
if I proposed this in code we might do
something like this
if we want to store an integer we're of
course going to need to store like int n
will call it and will represent 42 or 50
or 13 but if we want to create a data
structure we might want to start giving
this data structure our name I called it
a moment ago node which is a CS term for
like a node in the linked list so to
speak and it looks like this so type def
means give me my own type struct means
make it a structure like a student was
and then node was going to be the name
of this thing and I'll explain in a
moment why I have the word node twice
this time but I left room on the board
for just one more line in addition to an
INT called
n or whatever I need to somehow
represent in code the additional memory
that I want malloc to give me for the
address so first of all these are
addresses of what data types each of
those three new boxes they're the
addresses of integers in that point in
the story but technically what is this
box really pointing to is it pointing
specifically to the int it's pointing to
that whole chunk of memory if you will
so if you start thinking about each of
these rectangle
as being a node and each of the arrows
is pointing to another node we need to
somehow Express I need to somehow store
a pointer to a node in other words each
of these arrows needs to point to
another node and in code we could say
this right like let's give it a name
instead of n which is the number let's
call it next
so next shall be the name of this field
that points to the next node in memory
and nodes star what does that mean in
English if you will say again pointing
to an address right it looks different
node is a new word today and that's fine
but node star just means a pointer to a
node the address of a node and it turns
out that this is a custom structure so
we actually have to say this but it's
the same principle even though things
are kind of escalating quickly here we
just need two values an int and then a
pointer to another thing that other
thing is going to be another node and
we're just using a node frankly to
encapsulate two values an int and a
pointer and the way you express in C
albeit somewhat cryptically a pointer or
one of those arrows is you say give me a
variable called next have it point to a
structure called node or rather have it
be the address of a structure of type
node yeah
good question so this feels like a
circular kind of definition because I'm
defining a node and yet inside of a node
is a node that is okay because of the
star it is necessary in C no remember
that C always is kind of red top to
bottom so accordingly this very first
line of code here type def struct node
at that point in the story when clang
has read that line it knows that a
phrase struct node exists exactly
exactly we didn't need to do this with
student because there were no pointers
involved to other students but yes in
this case so in short this tells clang
hey clang give me a structure called
node and then in here we say hey clang
each of those nodes shall have two
things in integer called n and a pointer
to another one of these data structures
of type node and call the whole thing
node it's a bit of a mouthful but all
this is is the following let me go ahead
and erase all of this all this data type
is if we get rid of the picture we drew
on the fly there is this says hey clang
give me a data structure that
pictorially looks like this it's divided
into two parts the first part is called
n the second type is called next this
data type is of type int this is a
pointer to another such node and that's
it even though the code looks complex
the idea is exactly that yeah
good question when the reason is for is
as just came up a moment ago clang and
see in general or kind of dumb it they
just read code top to bottom and the
problem is you have to declare the name
of this structure as being a struct node
before you actually use it it's similar
in spirit to our discussion of
prototypes why functions need to be
mentioned way up top this just says de
clang give me a type called struct node
you don't know what it's going to look
like yet but I'll finish my thought
later and then in here we're just
telling clang inside of that node should
be an integer as well as a pointer to
the very type of thing I'm in the middle
of defining but if I had left off the
word node up there and just said struct
you couldn't do that because it hasn't
seen the word and OD e yet that's all
other questions
all right so if I now have a data
structure called node I can use it to
kind of stitch together these linked
lists and maybe just to vary things a
little bit and to start giving away some
ducks would folks be comfortable with a
volunteering to solve a problem here
yeah okay come on up one two sure or you
can take a duck and run ok one two how
about three come on over here three so
if you want to be our first pointer
coming you can be number five come on
over here want to be number nine and one
more one more volunteer come on over
here yeah all right so I'll meet you
over here okay seventeen all right so if
you'd like to just so we picked this up
for those following along home if you
would like to just say hello to the
audience wonderful okay if you wouldn't
mind I was taking a big step back over
the ducks just so that we're a little
farther back let's go ahead and do this
if you're our first pointer if you could
come over here for instance and just
stand outside the ducks and if you guys
could come a little over here in front
is still fine so here we have the
makings of a linked list and what's your
name again
Tommy is our first pointer if you will
commies variable are we just gonna keep
track of the first element of the linked
list so if you could with your left hand
represent first just point over at
Andrea so Andrea is the number nine if
you could use your left hand to point at
number five and if you could use your
left hand yep to point at number 17 and
your left hand to just point at null
which we'll just call the ground so you
don't want to just point it randomly
because that would be like following a
bogus pointer so here means null all
right so this is a linked list all you
need to store a linked list of three
values is three nodes inside of which
are three integers and their left hands
represents that next pointer so to speak
commies a little different in that she's
not holding a value she's not holding an
integer rather holding just fur just the
name of the variable first so you're the
only one that's different here
fundamentally so suppose I want to
insert like the number 20 good someone
volunteered to be in the number 20 okay
come on up all right and what's your
name Eric Eric
you're the number 20 and Eric actually
let's see let's see let's actually can
we do this let me give let me make this
a little more different okay that never
happened okay Eric give me that please I
want to insert Eric as number five so
Eric I'm keeping this list sorted so
we're obviously you're gonna go all
right but before you do that let's just
consider what this looks like in code
encode presumably we have Malick's Eric
from the audience I've given him a value
n of number five and his left hand is
like it's garbage value right now
because it's not pointing to anything
specific so he's got two values an
integer and a left hand representing the
next pointer if the goal is to put Eric
in sorted order what should our steps be
like whose hand should point where and
in what order yeah give us one step okay
so you should point at number nine which
is equivalent to saying point at
whatever first or call me is pointing at
so go ahead and do that
all right next what's the next step
someone else someone else almost there
yeah
okay so first Acoma could you point to
five and that's fine you don't even have
to move right this is the beauty of a
link list it doesn't matter where you
are in memory it's the whole beauty of
these pointers where you can literally
point at that other location it's not an
array where they need to be standing
back to back to back they can be
pointing anywhere all right let's go
ahead and insert one more who wants to
be say fifty-five big value yeah come on
down all right what's your name kion
okay so come on over so we've just now
locked kion from the audience I've given
him his end value of fifty five his left
hand is just some garbage value right
now how do we insert kiyong in the right
order
where is he obviously supposed to go in
sorted order he obviously belongs at the
end but here's the catch with a linked
list just like when we discussed
searching and sorting in the past a
computer is pretty blind to all but just
one value and the length list at the
moment like I don't know that these
three of these four exist all I know
really is that Komi exists because via
this first pointer is the only access to
the rest of the elements and so what's
cool about a linked list but perhaps not
obvious is that you only the most
important value is the first because
from the first value can get to everyone
else it's not useful excuse me for me to
remember Andrea Andrea alone because if
I do I've just lost track of call me and
more importantly because of his number
Eric so all I have to do really is
remember Komi so if the goal now is to
insert number 55 what steps should come
first
no pun intended I'm Sega okay finding
the first space so I'm gonna start at
homee and I'm gonna follow this pointer
number 5 does 55 belong here no so I'm
gonna follow this pointer and get to
Andrea does 55 belong here no kind of
follow her pointer and 22 does it belong
here
no and follow this pointer 26 no but you
have a free hand it turns out so what
step should come next we could have you
point at 55 and now done so relatively
simple but what was the running time of
this
yeah it's Big O of n it's linear because
I had to start at the beginning even
though we humans have the luxury of just
eyeballing it saying Oh
obviously he belongs way at the end not
in code like we have to start at the
beginning to reverse the whole darn list
until we get linearly to the very end
and now we're done let's try one last
one how about 20 yeah right come on down
what's your name James alright James
alright so we just malloc James giving
him the number 20 he obviously belongs
roughly in the middle what's the first
step sorry alright so we start with Komi
again alright first okay five do you
belong here no let me follow the link
okay nine do you belong here no do you
belong 22 but what did I just do wrong I
went too far at least in this story like
I literally Andrea's behind me now okay
so can I follow the pointer backwards
you can't like in every picture we've
drawn in every example we've done with
an address we only have the address of
the next pointer we don't have what's
called a doubly linked list at least in
this story where I can just turn around
so that was a bug so I need to start
over instead first okay 5 ok 19 what I
really need in code ultimately is to
kind of peek ahead and not actually move
not that far just the 22 beak a head at
22 and realize oh that's going to be too
far this is not yet far enough so let's
go ahead and bring James over oh
actually you can stay there physically
but what step happens to happen first I
know now he belongs in here you want to
point at him okay pointed him well let's
do that just because it is incorrect
that's fine okay Andrea proposed that we
point here but you just broke the whole
linked list why right no one is
remembering what was your name again no
one remembered where Keyon was so can't
do that your left hand has to stay there
so what step should happen first instead
James should point at whatever Andrea is
pointing at perhaps so a little
redundantly at the moment just like
before okay now what happens next
that's step one now you can point at him
okay good do that alright and so now
this looks like a complete mess but if
we know that call me is first we can
follow these breadcrumbs to to Eric and
then to Andrea and then to James and
then the rest of our list step by step
by step so it's a huge amount of like
logic now but what problem have we
and I think we identified it over here
earlier what was the problem first and
foremost with the raise you have to
decide on their size in advance and once
you do that if you want to add an
additional element you have to resize
the whole darn thing which is expensive
because you have to move everyone around
now frankly I'm being a little greedy
here and every time we've inserted these
new elements I've been keeping them in
sorted order so it would seem that if
you insert things in sorted order Big O
of n every time because in the worst
case the new element might end up all
the way at the end but what if we
relaxed that constraint what if I'm not
so uptight and need everything nice and
like orderly and sorted what if I just
want to keep growing the list in any
random order and I allocate the number
34 where and I'll play the number 34
Mal'akh 34 where is the quickest place
for me to go okay I'll point to five and
then combing if you could point to meat
done one well two steps alright suppose
now I malloc 17 with someone else with
the pretend is right here where's the
best place for 17 to go right after Co
me - so now calm you can point at 17-17
can point at me I can point at Eric and
so forth and that's two steps again two
steps if it's the same number up steps
every time we call that constant time
and we write it as Big O of one and so
here - it's just a trade off if you want
really fast insertions don't worry about
sorting just put them at the beginning
and deal with it later if you want
dynamic resizing bility don't use an
array use a linked list and just keep
allocating more and more as you go
without wasting a huge amount of space
to which notice that's another big
problem with an array if you over
allocate space and only use part of it
you're just wasting space so there's no
one solution here but we do now have the
capabilities thinks this trucks and
point pointers to stitch together if you
will these new problems yes please and
Who am I in this story oh okay
absolutely so another very reasonable
idea would be well why don't I just put
the new ones at the end that's fine if I
keep track of who is at the end the
problem is at the moment in the story
and we'll ultimately see this in code
I'm only remembering come--and from call
me am i getting everywhere else
I could have another pointer a second
pointer and literally call it last
that's equivalent to you or that's
always pointing at you
I just need then two pointers one
literally called first one literally
called last that's fine
that's a nice optimization if I want to
throw all of the elements at the end and
frankly I could get really fancy and to
solve the problem that Andrea cited
earlier if I store not just an int and a
pointer but instead an int and two
pointers I can even have each of these
guys pointing with their left and right
hands in a doubly-linked list so as to
solve the problem Andrea identified
which was if I go too far no big deal
take one step back I don't have to think
as hard about that logic so they're two
a trade off let's go ahead and take a
five-minute break I'll turn on some
music grab a duck now if you'd like and
we'll return with some fancier data
structure still thanks all right so
we're back
so let's now translate some of these
ideas to code so if we can actually
solve this problem a little more
concretely than just having humans
pointing at each other so for instance
let's try to distill everything we've
been talking about into just a goal in
code of storing a list of numbers I
would propose that we can take like
three passes at this problem the first
would be let's just decide in advance
how many numbers we want to store so we
don't have to deal with all this
complexity with the pointing and the
pointers and all this and just hard code
that value somehow and just stop when
the user is inputted that many numbers
and no more two we can improve upon that
and at least let the user dynamically
resize their array so that if they
decide to input more numbers than we
intend it's gonna grow and deal with
that of course arrays are not
necessarily ideal because we have to do
all that damn copying from old to new
that's linear time it seems smartest to
get to version 3 which is actually gonna
use a linked list so we're just more
modestly allocating space for another
number and another number and another
number or really a node one number at a
time so let me go ahead and start as
follows I'm gonna go ahead and include
some familiar lines in list zero dot C
of the cs50 library just to make it easy
to get some user input for this and
standard i/o dot H for printf and then
let me go ahead and declare my main
function as usual and then in here let's
do a couple things first let's ask the
user for the capacity of the array that
we're going to use or rather let's do
this first
let me first
rewind and say you know what inte
numbers 50 well that's gonna be annoying
the type in 50 numbers we're gonna give
these are two numbers too at first that
he or she can type in next let's go
ahead and prompt the user for those
numbers so let me go ahead and say let's
do this let's at least clean this up a
little bit so that we can reuse this
value so we're don't have a magic number
it just came up in discussion actually
so while not I'm going to do that let me
fix this this will be my capacity of
size two and that's going to give me
that size and then I'm gonna keep track
of how many integers I've prompted the
user for so far so initially the size of
this structure is going to be zero but
its capacity so to speak is two so size
means how many things are in it capacity
means how many things can be in it and
while the size of this structure is less
than its capacity let's go ahead and get
some inputs from the user let's go ahead
and ask them for a number using our old
friend get int and just say give me a
number and then let me go ahead and
insert the number that they type in into
this array at location size like this
and then do size plus plus I think you
know I wrote it pretty quickly but let's
consider what I just did I initialize
size to zero because there's nothing in
it initially then I say while size is
less than the capacity of the whole
thing and capacity is two by default go
ahead and do the following give me an
int from the user
okay so int number gets int then put at
location size in my numbers array
whatever the human typed in number and
then increment size with plus plus all
right so on the first iteration size is
zero so numbers bracket zero gets the
first number numbers bracket one gets
the second number then size equals
capacity so it stops logically any
questions on the logic of this code
alright so once we have those numbers
let's just do something simple like for
int I get 0 I is less than the actual
size i plus plus let's just go ahead and
print out the number
you inputted percent I backslash n and
type out numbers bracket I all right so
if I made no typos in list zero dot C
then I'm going to go ahead and do dot
slash zero dot C I'm going to be
prompted for a couple numbers let's go
ahead and do one two you inputted one q
and put it to alright so not bad but
this is bad design arguably why just
find one fault it's correct but bad
design repetitive because I'm using a
couple loops Shore and it's
fundamentally it's very limited in
functionality why like how useful is
this program it's hard coding it too so
let's at least improve upon this a
little bit and get rid of this hard
coding why don't I at least ask the user
for something like this well instead of
just declaring the capacity let me go
ahead and say you know what let's just
replace the to get int and just say
capacity for instance alright and now if
I do this I'm gonna be prompted so make
list 0 dot slash list 0 1 the capacity
will be 2 1 2 that's nice but if I run
it again
and give it a capacity of 3 1 2 3
I get more capacity so that's nice it's
an improvement for sure there is a bug
here before I test it further can anyone
identify a bug or somehow crash this oh
oh go ahead if I don't even put an
integer or was that same comment up here
oh no because I'm rerunning it in each
time I don't need to worry about
previous runs of the of the bout of the
program yeah well I am iterating up to
size which could be capacity because now
they do end up being equivalent because
I'm filling the whole thing but let's
try this if you don't type in a value so
let me go ahead and rerun this my
capacity shall be duck all right so we
did handle that because get int does
that for me but I bet I can still break
this oh yeah let's always try something
negatives oh okay
so bad like cryptic looking message but
clearly has to do with the negative
value so I should probably be a little
smarter about this and recall from like
week one we did do this with Mario you
might have done this so I could do
something like do-while capacity is less
than one I could go ahead and say
capacity gets get int
capacity so just a little bit of error
checking to close the bug that you
identified all right so let's go ahead
and recompile this make list 0 whoops
make we're gonna start hearing that a
lot today ARMA t make list 0 dot slash
list 0 capacity will be three one two
three
now capacity will be negative one
doesn't allow it
capacity 0 doesn't allow it capacity one
yes so non exhaustively I've tested it
feels like it's in better shape okay but
this program while correct and while
more feature full still has this
fundamental limit wouldn't it be nice to
allow the user to just keep typing
numbers as many as they want and then
quit once they're done in putting
numbers right if you're making a program
to compute someone's GPA different
students might have taken different
courses you don't want to have them to
type in all 32 courses if they're
younger and having taken all those
courses like there's a lot of scenarios
where you don't know in advance how many
numbers the user wants to provide but
you want to support few numbers lots of
numbers or beyond so let's do this in a
second version in list one dot C let me
go ahead and improve upon that example
as follows first let me give my familiar
friends up here cs50 dot H for IO
and I Oh dot H and then in here int main
void and then let's start writing this
so now I don't know in advance
necessarily how many numbers the user is
going to type in like the goal is I want
them to be able to type in a number
another number another number and then
hit the equivalent of like a queue for
quit when they're done in putting
numbers like I don't want them to have
to think about in advance how many
numbers it is they're inputting but how
do I do that like I can't just come up
with an array called numbers and say 50
because if the user wants to type in 51
numbers I'm gonna have to resize that
but how do you resize an array how do
you resize an array what's that you
can't write we've never seen an instance
where you've resized an array we talked
about it on the blackboard here well
just like allocate a bigger one and copy
everything in and we did identify
realloc but you can't actually use
realloc on an array realloc actually
accepts an address of a chunk of memory
that you want to grow or shrink so it
turns out if we now start to harness
this sort of fundamental definition of
what an array is a chunk of memory we
can actually build arrays ourselves if
an array is just a chunk of memory or
more specifically it's like the address
of the first byte of a chunk of memory
it would seem that I could declare my
array not with square brackets as we've
been doing for weeks but I can say you
know what numbers really is it's really
just a pointer and I'm initially gonna
initialize it to null because there is
no array but now I have the ability to
point that pointer at any chunk of
memory small or big now why is this
useful well initially let me claim that
my capacity is 0 because nothing's going
on yet I haven't called malloc or
anything and initially my size is 0
because there's nothing in the array and
it doesn't even have a size but let me
just do this forever much like in
scratch we had the forever block you can
use while true and see to just say keep
doing this until the user breaks out of
this and let me go ahead and ask the
user give me a number get int and just
ask them for a number and then we just
need a place to put that
so where do I put this number well do I
have at the moment any place to put the
number no and technically speaking how
do you express that like in pseudocode I
want to say if no place for number but
technically I could do this well if the
size of the array at the moment equals
its capacity that feels like a
lower-level way of expressing the same
thing if whatever the capacity is if the
size is the same there is no more room
and that simple statement also covers
the scenario where the capacity is zero
the size is therefore zero so it's the
same question either we have no space at
all or we have some space but we've used
at all size equals equals capacity so if
the size equals capacity or what put
more casually if I don't have enough
space what do I want to do intuitively
allocate more memory and it turns out
you proposed or someone proposed earlier
reallocating memory we can use this
function for the very first time let me
go ahead and say this I the catch with
realloc is you have to be smart about it
because it returns a pointer but so let
me propose this code first first kid
just give me a temporary variable call a
temp that's gonna store the following or
actually no let me let me do start this
more simply let me go ahead and say
numbers should be reallocated please
realloc by passing itself in and this
time give me the size of an int times
how many ants do I want this time how
many you can input in how many numbers
did the human just input presumably just
one right because literally we've only
called get it once in this story so
whatever the size of this array is now
we need to increase it by one that's all
so this line of code here is saying hey
paid computer go ahead and I'll
reallocate this array from whatever its
current size is and make it this size
instead the size of whatever it is plus
one times the size of an int
that's what we're trying to store is an
INT so we have to do that multiplication
and realloc is mentioned earlier is
pretty fancy it's gonna take in a
pointer whatever chunk of memory you've
already allocated and it's gonna then
reallocate a bigger chunk of memory
hopefully what's gonna happen is this if
your chunk of memory initially looks
like this it's gonna hopefully notice
all this memory is free let me just give
you back to the same address so if this
is address 100 and you get lucky and
this address is also available the
realloc function is going to remember
that for the operating system it's going
to return the number 100 again and
you're good to go you can safely touch
memory here or if this is in use already
this chunk of memory and therefore yeah
we can't fit another byte there because
some other pre code you wrote is using
that memory but there is twice as much
memory available down here what realloc
will do is if you've stored the number
50 it will handle the process of copying
50 to the new value this is going to be
left as a garbage value for you to deal
with and it's gonna return to you the
address of the new chunk of memory
having done the copying for you so even
though it's technically reallocating the
array it's not necessarily just going to
grow it it might relocate it in memory
to a bigger chunk and then give you the
new address of that memory question
it's a really good question honestly we
could avoid this problem slightly by
just doing you know what let's give me
at least go ahead and give me at least
the size of an ant x I don't know most
humans are not going to type in more
than 50 numbers let's just pick 50 so
you could do this and that would indeed
save you time because the approach I'm
currently taking is pretty inefficient
because every damn time like the user
calls get int and gives an INT we're
resizing resizing resizing very
expensive as to what the best value is
though 50 should be 25 should it be a
thousand I'm either going to under bet
or over bet and it just depends to on
you to decide which of those is the
worst decisions good question in
programs you're writing is it better to
have more memory than you're using or
should you really be conservative these
days memory is cheap we all have
gigabytes of memory and so wasting 50
bytes or 200 bytes times 4 of memory not
a big deal like just get the job done
quickly and easily but in resource
constrained devices maybe things like
phones or little Internet of Things
style devices that have a lot fewer
resources you don't really want to go
wasting bytes but honestly the CPU is
the brains and our computers are so darn
fast these days even if you're calling
malloc ten times a thousand times it's
happening so darn fast that the human
doesn't even notice so there - these are
what are called design decisions and
these are the kinds of things that in
the real world you might actually debate
with someone at a whiteboard saying no
this is stupid because of this reason or
he or she might push back for other
reasons and no one's necessarily right
the whole goal is to just have that
thought process first so you're at least
confident in what you chose yeah when
you were calling F read you were by
definition in the forensics problem set
reading bytes from disk into memory when
you were calling F writes you were
copying bytes from memory back to disk
if that answers the question okay other
questions yeah
why do I say sighs plus one in line 16
because the whole goal is to make room
in this array for the newly inputted
number that the human just typed in and
so whatever the current size of the
array is I clearly need one more space
it does because it does repeat on and on
because at the moment I'm inside of this
while loop so we do need to ask a
question when is the human done
inputting and it turns out and this is
non-obvious and it's not the best user
experience on a keyboard for the human
but we can actually detect the following
sentiment if user is done in putting
numbers then let's go ahead and break
but the question then is how do you
express that pseudocode well you could
in some programs maybe type Q for quit
but is that going to work
when using get int could we detect Q why
not exactly because get in immediately
prompts you for another inch so because
of the way we designed the cs50 library
you can't detect Q or you can't have the
human type quit unless you don't use get
int you instead use we could use get
string and then every time the human
types in a number we could use like a to
I to convert it to an int but if the
human types in Q or Q uit a string also
we could just have an if condition with
stiring compare and quits but honestly
then you're reinventing like get in so
trade off anyhow a common way to work
around this would be you know that ctrl
C quits programs
perhaps cancels out of your program
there's another popular keystroke
control D that sends what's called end
of file it simulates the end of a file
it simulates the end of the humans input
so it's kind of like the period at the
end of an English sentence so if you
want to signal to a computer that's
waiting for input from you that you
don't want to quit the program that
would be ctrl C but you just want to be
done inputting input to the computer you
hit control D otherwise known as a Oh F
and the way to express this and you
would only know this from documentation
would be to say something
this if the number the human typed in
equals end of file but there is no such
thing in this context you actually do
this because of how the cs50 library
works turns out and then if the only
values a function you can return our
integers that means you can return 0 1
negative 1/2 billion negative 2 billion
give or take what humans did for years
with old programming languages is they
just steal one or a few numbers for
instance you steal like the number 2
billion and call it int max the maximum
integer and you just say you can never
actually type 2 billion because we are
using that as a special value to signify
that the human hit ctrl D or you could
do negative 2 billion or you could do 0
or 50 but at some point you have to
steal one of the 4 billion available
numbers to use as a sentinel value a
special value that you can then check
for is a constant so anyhow this just
means when the user's done their typing
input go ahead and break out of this
while loop and as an aside let me fix
one thing it turns out things can go
wrong with realloc and if realloc fails
to allocate memory it can return null a
special value that just means something
went wrong it's an invalid pointer it's
the address 0 and so it turns out
there's a subtle bug here where
technically I should actually do this
store Ari Alex return value in a
temporary variable because if temp
equals null something went wrong and I
should actually go ahead and quit out of
this program but let me wave my hand at
that for now because it's more of a
corner case but you'll see in the online
version of this program we have
additional error checking that just
checks in the rare case that realloc
fails clean it up and return properly
but I'll wave to the online code for
that all right any questions on that
example before we move on yeah
yes good question when you call realloc
and it ends up allocating more space
does it clear the original memory no and
that is where garbage values come from
for instance because if they're just
left in memory from the previous use
other questions yeah user actually type
to break Oh control D control D and it's
not Brahe it's just send end of file end
of input
control C kills or breaks out of the
program itself same as int max yes
correct
in the cs50 library int max yes is the
symbol yes yeah absolutely we could add
more logic and you can use getstring and
we could prompt him to her hey do you
want to input another number only
downside of that would be now I have to
type in not only my number but like yes
or no constantly so just a trade-off
user interface wise all right so let me
go ahead and let me go ahead and return
0 here just as my simple solution to
this problem of something going wrong
I've just compiled this program let me
go ahead and run it I'm gonna type in
one number two numbers three numbers and
now I'm bored I don't want to keep doing
this how do I tell the computer I'm done
control D and oh okay that's correct
behavior because I forgot a key step
what's that
yeah I'm not actually doing anything
with the values I should probably like
for int int I get 0 I less than sighs i
+ + code we had before and I should
probably print out you inputted % I
comma this save that make list 1 so all
I did was riad the printing code now if
I rerun this 1 2 3
control D damn it oh ok now I broke my
code here let me do this we're gonna get
rid of this error checking because I'm
not actually ever resizing numbers gets
realloc oh and maybe someone was trying
timing in with this numbers brackets
size gets the users input size + + was
this a key detail someone wanted me to
do okay so I didn't actually finish the
program earlier notice we left off as
follows hey computer give me an array of
size 0 initially that's null there's no
memory for it therefore the size of this
array is 0 do the following forever get
a number from the human if the number
equals this special value int max just
breakout because the program is done and
actually sorry this is why I write these
in advance - okay go ahead and prompt
the user for number if they have
inputted the control D just break out of
this loop however if the size of the
array equals its current capacity go
ahead and reallocate space for this
thing being 1 number bigger than it
previously was now assuming that since
succeeded and we have memory go ahead
and just like our list zero example
store in the numbers array at the
current location which is zero whatever
number the human typed in and then
increment the size by one - remember
what we have done
I'm also though going to need to do
capacity plus plus here to remember that
we've increased the capacity of the
array so again two new measures capacity
is how much space there is in total size
is how much we're using they happen to
be identical at the moment because we're
growing this thing step by step by
yep alright let me go ahead and hit save
let me go ahead and compile this one
last time dot slash list 1 and input 1 2
3 ctrl D and ok now it's just an
aesthetic bug
I forgot my backslash n so just to prove
that I can actually program dot slash
list 1 1 2 3 ctrl D all right so you
inputted 1 and the reason it didn't move
to another line is because ctrl D gets
sent immediately without hitting Enter
alright oh that's all using arrays now
let's do the sort of cake baked already
and pull it out of the oven the third
and final example here is list 2 and
actually before we get there let me note
one thing yeah let's do one last thing
here let me go ahead and run per earlier
our new friend valgrind on list 1 enter
it's waiting for me to type in 1 2 3 let
me go ahead and hit control D
interesting I seem to have a buggy
program even though I claimed a moment
ago that I knew what I was doing 12
bytes in 1 blocks are definitely lost in
lost record 1 of 1 again I don't
understand most of those words but 12
bytes definitely lost probably my fault
why is it 12 and what are those 12 bytes
yeah yeah 1 2 & 3
exactly I typed in three numbers 1 2 & 3
each of those is 4 bytes on this
computer that's 12 3 times 4 and so I
never freed them seems to be the source
of the issue so at the end let's just
prove that valgrind can detect
correctness as well free my numbers
semicolon let me go ahead and rerun make
list 1 and now let me increase the size
of this and do valgrind again on list 1
typing in the same values 1 2 & 3
control d all heap blocks were freed no
leaks are possible so again valgrind is
your friend they find problems that you
didn't even necessarily notice and you
didn't have to have read through your
lines of code again and again to
identify the source of the issue
necessarily alright any questions then
on these arrays that are dynamically
allocated and the bugs we find therein
with valgrind all right so the last
demonstration of code is going to be
this I have stolen for this final
example some of the building blocks that
we had on the screen earlier in my code
for list 2 dot C I need a structure
called node and that node as we claimed
earlier with our human volunteers is
going to contain a number called number
we'll call it this time instead of n and
it's going to contain a pointer called
next to another such node so that's
copied and pasted earlier albeit with
the integer rename to number for clarity
now notice in main what I'm doing first
go ahead and allocate an array of no
space initially so this was like when
Comey was holding up first and
representing the beginning of our data
structure this is the analog using an
array that the piece of paper that would
be held up here would be numbers and
it's just pointing at nothing null like
left hand down on the floor because
there's no memory yet allocated but then
go ahead and while true go ahead and get
an integer from the user with this code
here check if the user hit ctrl D as
with this arcane technique and then our
code is similar in spirit but we have to
stitch these things together allocate
space for the number so when i'm a loc'd
an additional volunteer from the
audience and he or she came down the
equivalent in code is this hey computer
locate with malloc enough space to fit
the size of a node then store the
results in a pointer called n so nodes
star n just means give me a pointer to a
node call it n and store the address
that was just allocated from the
audience as before why do I have these
lines of code here that I've highlighted
in blue
what's that expressing if bang N or if
not n would be how you pronounce it
what's going on there exactly this isn't
gonna happen all that often but if the
computer is out of memory and therefore
malloc fails you don't want the program
just to fret crash or freeze like all of
us hate when that happens on Mac OS or
Windows so check for it if not N or
equivalently if n equals equals null
just return one quit gracefully even
though annoyingly but don't just crash
or do something unexpected so you can
simplify that check to just if not n if
n is not a valid pointer return one now
here's the code with which we were
implementing the demonstration with our
humans and this is the scariest looking
or most cryptic at least looking code
we're gonna say in C today is our final
day and see sort of the we've been
running up a really steep hill of late
learning about memory and now data
structures and syntax this is the last
of our syntax in C so what are the
symbols to be aware of this line of code
here is how I handed one of our
volunteers a piece of paper on the right
hand side is the number that was typed
in 55 or 5 or 20 or whatever the value
is on the left hand side is where you
want to put it in and then literally an
arrow number does this it has with
malloc a liner so prior given me in
memory just one of these big rectangles
and again the top of this in this
example is called number and the bottom
is called next so that's our human
having stood up from the back of the
room when I hand that human a number
like 55 it visually goes there
of code with which you achieve that is
this here because notice on line 31 here
when i'm a loc'd that node i stored its
address in a variable called n and
that's a pointer as drawn with an arrow
to that big node or if we really want to
be nitpicky if this is an address 100
yes then the pointer actually has the
value 100 in it but again that's rarely
useful information so we can abstract
away with just an arrow so line 31 is
what creates those boxes on the screen
line 38 is what puts the number for
instance 55 into the box
exactly much like I handed a piece of
paper over so what is this this is the
only real new notation today even though
we're using lots of stars elsewhere
arrow this is wonderfully the first time
in see it actually maps to our pictures
if n is the variable and you do n arrow
something that means follow the arrow
kind of like chutes and ladders if you
grew up playing that and then put the
number where the arrow has led you in
the fields called number so as an aside
we can think about this a different way
and is what data type what is this thing
in blue n it's a pointer and it's a
pointer to one of these things that we
created earlier so we're not doing
students anymore with our structures
we're implementing nodes which have
numbers and next pointers so it turns
out that if n is a node or n is a
pointer to a node recall that dot
notation from before this is not how you
access number in this case because n is
not a node itself it's a pointer but if
n is a pointer how do you go to a
pointer how do you go to an address with
what notation star so recall from last
week if we want to go to an address you
could do syntax like this ignore the
parentheses for a moment just star n
means if n is an address of a chunk of
memory star n means go there once you're
there you're like conceptually right
here top left hand corner how do you
access individual fields like number or
next you use dot notation so if you
literally do star n
dot number that means go to the address
and access the number field there's nice
syntactic sugar in C which is just a
fancy way of saying shorthand notation
which is the arrow but that's all it is
this arrow notation doesn't do anything
new it just combines go there with
access a field in a struct all in one
breath if you will and this just is
looks a little prettier this when I told
our volunteers earlier point your hand
down at the floor that's all that line
of code is doing it's saying go to ends
address which is here access the next
field and write in that field null which
is just the address 0 the default
special address like pointing at the
floor this line of code 40 is just a
quick error check if numbers what is
that equivalent to that's actually just
saying if numbers not equals null so if
numbers is legitimate if malloc works
correctly then let's go ahead and do the
following this is a mouthful what is
going on here so this is a for loop
that's not using numbers well or is it
almost every for loop we've written and
you've probably written just uses I J
maybe K but just integers probably but
that doesn't have to be the case what is
a pointer it's an address what is an
address a place in memory or a number
really so you can certainly use for
loops just involving addresses but how
so we'll consider this line of code this
here looks different today but it's
everything before that first semicolon
that's just where you initialize a value
so this is like saying hey computer go
ahead and give me a variable called PTR
and initialize it to be the start of my
list then I'm saying hey computer do
this so long as pointer does not equal
null and then what am i doing
if and let's ignore this for now is an
error check go ahead and sorry let me
think for one second
if okay let's do this
what is what are these lines of code
doing this is the code that was actually
suggested at the very end of our human
example like what if we wanted to insert
all of the elements at the end of the
linked list how do you express that
so in this highlighted lines of code
we're asking the question if the current
pointers next field is null we found the
end go ahead and update that next field
to equal n and then break so let me
translate this to an actual picture for
using smaller boxes that makes clear
where something is going so suppose that
this programs been running for a little
while and we have a linked list that
looks like this where this one's
pointing here and maybe this one's
pointing here and this says null here
and this points here and the numbers are
as we've been using today 4250 13 so the
start of this list is called numbers
this points to the start of the list
what am i doing in this for loop I am
just implementing the following logic
with this loop give me a variable called
pointer as represented in the story by
like my left finger here and initialize
that to be the start of the list if that
nodes next pointer is not is equal to
null add a new node here but this is not
null I want to follow the breadcrumbs to
here and then oh we're at the end of the
list
I want to insert' this new thing here so
how do i express this code actually in C
so if I look back up here this is the
line of code that allocates my left
finger here called pointer and
initialize it to equal numbers which is
the same as pointing at the first
element it's kind of like Co me was
representing first earlier but now our
array is called numbers next what am i
doing does pointer equal null will know
if my left hand is pointing here it
obviously doesn't equal null so we don't
have to worry yet then what do I want to
do
if pointer next equals null well what
does that mean well pointer is here
pointer arrow next means here does this
equal null in this story I mean it
literally doesn't because it's null it's
not written there null is way down there
so the condition does not pass so what
do I do next
if pointer is equal to null doesn't
apply here's a weird update pointer gets
pointer next
so it's cryptic looking syntax but if
pointer is pointing here what is pointer
next that's just this right this is n
this is next or this is number this is
next
so pointer next is this so what is this
value well this is a pointer pointing
here so that highlighted block of code
pointer equals pointer next has the
effect visually of doing this why if the
arrows are a little too magical just
think about these being addresses if
this is saying the next address is
location 100 pointer equals pointer next
is like saying well this also equals 100
whatever 100 is for instance over here
is what both arrows should now point at
and if you now repeat this process and
repeat this process
eventually that question we asked
earlier is going to apply if pointer
next equals null what do I want to do
well if pointer next equals null there's
two lines going on pointer next equals n
so pointer next is no longer null it
should instead be pointing at n which is
the new note and then that's it because
this was already initialized to null and
let's propose this was 55 and we're done
so so much easier to do obviously in
person with just humans moving around
and pointing with their arrows with
their left hands but in code you just
have to think about the basic building
blocks what is each of these values
where is each of it pointing and which
of those fields do you need to update
and the only new code here even though
we're kind of combining it all in one
massive example is this we are actually
using arrow notation to say go to that
address and access some value there in
and this condition down here which I'll
wave my hand out for now just handles
the situation where the Liz
is initially empty any questions on this
thus far all right
so let's take a look more graphically at
some final problems we can solve and
what you'll see in the in the days ahead
is the following when it comes to these
linked lists and more we now have the
ability to Alex really allocate things
in memory dynamically we don't
necessarily know in advance how many
numbers we have or in the case of the
next problem said how many words we have
we have the ability though to use malloc
and maybe even realloc to grow and grow
our data structure in memory and we have
the ability in code to actually traverse
those values in such a way that we can
access memory that's all over the board
now and not necessarily back to back to
back but what happens if we want to
combine these ideas into fancier
solutions still well let's take a look
at that in particular if I go let's say
over here to the following let's
consider a problem we might now solve if
I wanted a store everyone's name in this
room in a data structure I could do what
well we could use an array so I could
actually draw it decide how many people
are in the room let's call it in and
actually draw end boxes on the board and
then iteratively ask everyone for their
name and actually write it down if I
then wanted to take attendance at their
after and say oh is Alice here or is Bob
here or is Kareem here or Brian I could
just look through that array and say yes
or no that human is here but what's the
running time of that algorithm how long
would it take to look up a name in a
data structure where I've just drawn it
as an array a big list on the board
what's that a Big O of n right because
if it's just a list of names it's gonna
take Big O of N and frankly that seems a
little slow how could I do an
optimization well what if we combine
some of these ideas arrays are nice
because they give me random sort of
instant access to memory locations but
linked lists are nice because they allow
me to dynamically add or subtract
elements even if I want from the list so
you know what instead of writing down
everyone's names like Alice and Bob and
Charlie like this in just one big array
of some fixed size
that necessary into a corner now I only
have room for one more name what if I
instead do things a little more cleverly
so when I'm actually jotting down
everyone's name in the room what if I
instead did okay is Alice here alright
alice is here and then Brian is here I'm
gonna put Brian here and then maybe
Charlie is here
alright so Charlie and then maybe Arnold
is here where should I put Arnold so
also starts with a you know what let's
just put Arnold here Arnold and let's go
and Abbey is here so you know what let's
just put Abby up here as well Bob came
as well so Bob so what's the pattern I'm
obviously following is I'm hearing names
called out alphabetically sorted kind of
like Abby kind of ended up in the weird
place here but that's fine because I
didn't hear her name first but I did
kind of bucket eyes people in two
different rows of the board in other
words all of the a names I seemed to
just write down for convenience at the
top and then all the B names together
and C names and probably if I kept going
I could do this all the way through Z in
the English alphabet so what's nice
about this is that yeah I'm making lists
of names but how long is each of those
lists if there's n people in the room
each of my list is not going to be and
long which is slow it's going to be what
and divided by 26 give or take if we
assume that there's an equal number of
people with Z names and a names it's
going to be roughly n divided by 26 so
that I have these like chains of human
names but they're much shorter than they
would have been if I just grouped
everyone together and this is a
fundamental technique in programming
called
hashing it turns out there are things in
this world called hash functions these
are just mathematical or verbal or code
implemented functions that take as input
something and produce as output a number
typically a number from 0 to say 25 or
from 1 to 26 but they can also output
strings in other contexts as well so my
hash function here in my mind is if you
hand me a name I'm gonna look at the
first letter in your name and if it's a
I'm putting you in location 0 if it's B
I'm gonna put you in location 1 if it's
a Z I'm gonna put you in location 25 at
the end so these are all
Kitt's I've got so to speak in computer
science like 26 buckets or room on the
board that represent the starts of
people's names so what is that well it
would seem that if I don't know in
advance how many a names I have that's
kind of like drawing this as a linked
list if you will that might just get
longer and longer but I do know that I
only have a finite number of first net
letters so that at the risk of drawing a
little messily is kind of like drawing
what data structure it's kind of like
drawing an array that just has 26 spots
and what's nice about an array is that I
have random access I can jump right to
any letter of the alphabet in constant
time one step and once I get there I'm
still gonna see a list of names
thankfully thanks to linked lists that
list can be short or long but on average
let's say it's gonna be one twenty sixth
the length that it would have been if I
just used one array or one linked list
so this technique of using a hash
function which again I've defined as you
give me a name
I take that as input I look at the first
letter and I return is output a number
from 0 to 25 a hash function lets you
create a hash table and there's
different ways to implement hash tables
but perhaps one of the most common is
indeed like this you decide in advance
on the size of an array but that array
does not contain the strings or the
humans names that array actually
contains a linked lists and it's the
linked lists that contain the names so
we borrow ideas from like week two we
merge them with an idea today from week
four of adding a raise to linked list
respectively and we kind of get the best
of both worlds because I can immediately
jump to any letter of the alphabet super
fast and once I'm there yeah there's a
list but it's not nearly as long as it
would have been if I didn't use this
trick so what's the running time of all
of this well it turns out that a hash
table in the worst case might still take
you how many steps to find someone's
name once it's been added to the list
the very worst case how many steps if
there's n people in the room maybe n why
it's kind of a perverse situation but
can you contrive a scenario in which
even though
doing this fanciness it still takes me n
steps to confirm or deny that someone's
here yeah everyone's name starts with
the same letter for some weird reason
now it's a little silly in the human
world but it could happen if you're just
walking data or whatever in the in the
computer world this can devolve into
sure an array with just one really long
linked list but in practice that's not
likely gonna happen right if we actually
spent the time here and asked everyone
for their name we'd probably get a
reasonably uniform distribution of
letters at least as as is statistically
likely with just human names so that
would kind of spread things out and so
there's this fundamental distinction
between sort of real world running time
or wall clock time how many seconds are
actually spinning on the clock versus
asymptotic running time we've talked for
a couple weeks now about running time as
being Big O of n and that might be still
the case that a hash table yes in the
worst case it's still a Big O of n data
structure because in the worst case
that's gonna take n steps but in the
real world Big O of n is really big o of
n divided by 26 even though we always
ignore those lower order terms but when
it's you the human running the code and
analyzing the data running 26 times
faster is actually real time saved even
though a mathematician might say yeah
that's the same fundamentally and indeed
one of the problems ahead for the next
problem set is going to be suss to suss
out exactly what the implications are in
your own code for actual wall clock
running time and making smarter designs
to decisions like something like this
can actually really speed up your code
to be 26 times as fast even though yes a
theoretician would say AB but that's
still asymptotically or mathematically
equivalent to just something linear so
it's this fine tuning that'll make your
code even better and better now frankly
hashing on first names probably isn't
the smartest thing alone right like it
does anyone's this is gonna be hard
especially it does anyone's name start
with Z here violets not here but thank
you for that perfect counter example but
she's not here so look there's no Z so
now we're down to 25 possible values and
I could probably pick some less common
letters to the pointers there's probably
a few more a's than there are Z's or a
few more bees than there are queues just
by nature of human names
so maybe just choosing the first letter
isn't good
and frankly with twenty six names
suppose we did this for all of Harvard
and had thousands of names each of my
chains might still have hundreds or
thousands of names so another design
question is going to be well how many
buckets should you have how big should
the array be maybe you shouldn't look at
the first letter what if you look at the
first and the second letter together so
a a and a B and a C and then dot dot dot
b a b c BB C so you could come up with
more and more buckets but what else how
else might we kind of uniformly
distribute people what do all of you
have that we could use as input to a
hash function okay what you can do last
name which might give us a different or
similar distribution yeah what's that
you can use your ID number and actually
look at the first digit of your ID and
odds are at zero through nine so we
could probably at least get ten buckets
that way and that's probably uniformly
distributed I'm not sure we could use
birth birth dates in some way like we
could put all the freshmen in one bucket
all the seniors in another bucket and
everyone else and so forth in their own
buckets which would also give us some
input so again a hash function is
entirely up to you to program and design
the goal though is to smooth things out
you want to have roughly the same number
of things in each linked list just so
that you have found about the same
performance across all of these various
inputs so let's take a look at a couple
of other data structures again in this
abstract way now that we know that even
though it's not obvious at first attempt
we know how to construct arrays we kind
of know now how to construct linked
lists it stands to reason we could
implement them together in code what
else could we do now with these building
blocks so for instance this structure
here is a very common one known as a
tree tree like a family tree where
there's one patriarch or matriarch at
the top and then their children and then
their grandchildren and
great-grandchildren and so forth and
what's nice about a tree structure is
that if you're storing data you can
actually store the data in clever ways
to the left child to the right child and
so forth as follows
notice here there's something curious
about all the numbers in this data
structure what is noteworthy about them
what is noteworthy yeah what's that
they are multiples of 11 that was just
to make them look pretty though
by the author here yeah yeah there's a
mathematical significance to like no
matter what node or circle you look at
the value in it is bigger than the left
child and it's smaller than the right
child so it's kind of in between any
circle you look at the number to the
left is smaller if the number to the
right is bigger and I think that applies
universally all over the place yes so
what does that mean well recall from
like week 0 when we had a whole bunch of
like numbers that we were phone book
pages that we were searching 1 2 3 4 5 6
let's give ourselves a 7th one recall
that when we did divide and conquer or
binary search we did it on an array and
what was nice about binary search was we
started in the middle and then we maybe
went left or we maybe went right and we
kind of divided and divided and divided
and conquered the problem much more
efficiently in the logarithmic time than
it would have been if we did it linearly
but we know now weeks later that are
raised kind of limiting right
if I keep storing all of my values in an
array what can I not do with the array
make it bigger right I can't add an
elements to it without copying every
darn element as we've discussed thus far
today but what if I was a little smarter
about it what if I stored my values not
just in an array but I started storing
them in these circles let's call them
nodes and each of those nodes is really
just an integer plus two additional
values how would we implement this data
structure in memory well here's an int n
could represent the number in question
and we could put that in a data
structure called a node that just has
the same syntax as earlier today but
I've left room for two more fields what
is it that I want to represent in code
if I want to start storing my numbers
not in this old school week zero array
but in a tree to two pointers right a
tree as drawn here with literally with
arrows is just like saying every one of
these nodes or circles has a left child
and a right child how do you implement
children well you can litter
just use pointer notation as well here a
left child is just a pointer to another
struct on the left and a right child is
just another pointer to the child on the
right and what's nice about this
ultimately is that we can now traverse
this tree just as efficiently as we can
traverse this array because notice if I
want to search for the number 66 how
many steps does it take me if I start at
the top just like Komi represented the
start of our linked list so in the world
of a tree does the root have special
significance and that's where we always
begin so how many steps does it take me
to find 66 given the top it looks like
yeah like 1 2 or 3 right I start at the
top I look at it say 55 which way do I
go I go to the right then I see 77 ok
which way do I go I go to the left so
it's the same logic as week 0 in
dividing and conquering the phone book
or an array a couple weeks later but we
get to the number we care about pretty
quickly and it's not linear and in fact
if we actually did out the math what's
really cool about a binary search tree
is that if you have n elements and
circles the height of that tree is by
definition mathematically log n so the
height of the tree just so happens to
correspond to exactly how many times you
can take n and divide it divide it
divided divided it in two and you can
actually see this if you think about it
the reverse direction on the bottom row
there are how many elements alright and
on the middle row there's two and on the
top row there's one so you can actually
see it in the reverse direction this is
like divide and conquer but in a
different conceptual way like it's being
divided every every row in the tree has
half as many elements as the one below
it and so the implication of that is
just like from week zero in the phone
book when we're dividing and dividing
and dividing in half and half and half
so this is only to say now that we have
structures and pointers we can build
something like this but let's try one
other example here - this is a
crazy-looking example but it's kind of
amazing suppose that if we wanted to
store a dictionary of words so not
humans names this time but like English
words so merriam-webster Oxford English
Dictionary has like what thousands
hundreds of thousands of words these
days in English for in
since how do you actually store those
well if you just look up words in a
dictionary
back in yesteryear like that is linear
like you have to start at the beginning
and look through it page by page looking
for words or you could be a little
smarter because the words in any
dictionary are hopefully alphabetized
you can do the Mike Smith style divide
and conquer by going to the middle in
the middle of the middle and so forth
log of n but what if I told you you
could look up words in constant time
some fixed number of steps none of this
divide and conquer complexity no log and
just constant time you want a word go
get it instantly that's where this last
structure comes in which is called a try
TR ie short for retrieval even though
it's pronounced the opposite so a try is
a trie each of whose nodes is an array
so it's like this weird Frankenstein's
monster kind of data structure we're
just really combining lots of different
ideas as follows and the way a try works
as is implied by this partial diagram on
the board is that if you want to store
the name Brian for instance in your
dictionary as the first word what you do
is you start by creating a tree with
just one node but that node is
effectively an array that array is of
size let's say for simplicity 26 so A
through Z this location here therefore
represents B for Brian so if I want to
insert Brian into this tree I create one
node at the top and then for the second
letter in his name R
I create another node also an array n
through Z and so here I put a pointer to
this node here B R I so I should have
drawn some more boxes by ABCD EFG H I so
here I'm gonna draw another pointer to
be weight by n okay
that's wrong I miss Billy shall be our
name Billy is that B weight yet no
that's no dammit bee bee bee IFE yes
this works this works ok sorry so here
we go we're inserting Billy into this
fancy data structure
so the first node represents the first
letter the second node represents the
second letter the third node represents
the third letter and so forth but what's
cool about this is the reusability so
notice if this is the second letter and
I counted this out correctly I this is
going to lead to a third node deeper in
the tree where it's L that we care about
next and then another one down here
which represents another L and I'll
start drawing the letters L this is B
this is I L and we'll call this L and
then finally another one over here
which is a y and this gets pointing down
here this gets pointing here and so
forth so in short we have one node
essentially for every letter in the word
that we're inserting into the data
structure now this looks stupidly
inefficient at the moment because to
store bi LLY how much memory did I just
use 26 plus 26 plus 26 plus 26 plus 26
just to store five characters I use 26
times five but this is kind of thematic
in computer science spend a little more
space and I bet I can decrease the
amount of time it takes to find anyone
because now no matter how many other
students are in this data structure and
for instance let's do another one if we
had another one like Bob so B is the
same first letter that leads us to the
second node o is somewhere else in this
array say over here so this represents O
and then Bob has another one so there's
going to be another array here and this
is why the picture above draws this so
succinctly this is how we might store
Bob so bill212 dn't sin the class or a
thousand students in the room we're
gonna have a lot of nodes there on the
board but how many steps does it take to
find
Billy or Bob or any name with this data
structure and to conclude yes or no that
student is in the class so like five
four Billy three four Bob and notice
none of that math has any relationship
to how many students are in the room if
we instead wrote out a long list of a
thousand names in the worst case it
might take me a thousand steps to find
Billy or Bob maybe I could be a little
smarter if I sort it but in the worst
case Big O of N it's linear or if I used
a a hash table before and maybe there's
a thousand students in the room but okay
there's 26 letters in the English
alphabet at least so that's 26 buckets
so maybe it's a thousand divided by 26
worst case if I'm using those chains
those linked lists inside my array but
wait a minute if I'm using this
structure a try where every node in the
tree is just in an array that leads me
to the next node Allah breadcrumbs B I
ll Y is five and always five Bo B is
always three Bri a n would have been
five as well
none of these totals has any impact or
any influence from the number of total
names in the data structure so a try in
some sense is this amazing like this
amazing holy grail in that by combining
these various data structures now you
get constant time but you do pay a price
and just to be clear what is the price
we seem to be paying memory and in fact
this is why I'm not really drawing it
much more because it just becomes a big
mess on the screen because it's hard to
draw such wide data structures it's
taking a huge amount of memory but
theoretically it's being coming faster
yeah question
ah good question so it's a bit of a
simplification if you were storing both
Bob and Bobby you would actually keep
going so each of these elements is not
just one letter
you also have essentially a node there
or some other data structure that says
either stop here or continue and you'll
see actually in the problems that will
propose to you how you can represent
that idea if you choose to go this route
indeed the challenge ahead ultimately is
something quite like this you will
implement your very own spell checker
and we will give you code that get you
started with this process and of course
the spell checker these days in Google
Docs and Microsoft Word
just like underlines in red misspelled
words but what's going on and how is it
that word or Google Docs can spell check
your English or whatever language so
quickly well it has a dictionary in
memory probably with tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of words and
all they're doing constantly is every
time you type a word and hit the
spacebar or period or enter it's quickly
looking up that new word or those words
in its dictionary and saying yes or no
should I squiggle a red line underneath
this word and so what we're going to do
is give you a big text file ASCII text
containing like a hundred plus thousand
words you're gonna have to decide how to
load those into memory not just
correctly but in a way that's well
designed and will even give you a tool
if you choose to use it that times how
long your code takes and it even counts
how much RAM you're actually using
but the key goals for this week and our
final week in C is to take some of these
basic building blocks like arrays and
pointers and structures and decide for
yourselves how you're most comfortable
stitching them together to what extent
you want to really fine-tune your code
beyond just getting it correct and it
give you a better sense of the
underlying code that people have had to
write for years and libraries to make
programming doable Allah scratch because
in just a few weeks we're going to
transition to Python and the dozens of
lines of code you've been writing now
are going to be whittled down to one
line to line because we're gonna get a
lot more features from these newer
fancier languages but you'll hopefully
have an appreciation of what is actually
going on underneath that hood so I'll
stick around for anyone I want questions
let's call it a day take a duck on your
way out for roommates as well we'll see
you next time